[Music]
well george there's a couple of uh very
interesting things have happened in the
uh
world of crypto oh yeah uh this one so
we've seen the big the big crash dave
and we've talked about billion dollars
lost in crypto scams
but the latest is that the crypto market
has now lost two
trillion dollars
in value
uh and this is from yahoo finance
investors had nowhere to hide on monday
as both the stock market and
cryptocurrencies tumbled the crypto
market saw its total market cap drop by
roughly 12 on monday to just 980 billion
the sector as a whole has now seen more
than two trillion dollars in losses
since its peak back in november
wow
so it's down what now 60 something
percent since september
that's a big hit and people are people
have been coming at me dave because you
know i've been making fun little videos
about crypto and they're saying well
what about the stock market well what
about the stock market this stuff's down
65 the stock market's down 20 can't you
add
no
the answer is no
what about the stock market it has a
70-year track record what's crypto got a
track record of you losing your butt
well the stock market is based on actual
companies that are producing actual
things that's a huge difference that
we're not talking about
crypto is just based on what one guy is
willing to pay for it and it produces
nothing which is why warren buffett
famously uh recently said that he
wouldn't
actually crash yeah he said i wouldn't
pay 25 dollars for all of it
and now it
and he actually
he may have overpaid if this keeps up
that's true he might be able to buy it
all for 25 at this point oh wow
and listen in case you were afraid that
this was going to be a problem
uh the
twitter co-founder and block ceo jack
dorsey
and rapper jay-z both known for their
financial prowess that's right um are
going to save you
they're going to take great care of you
because they have now opened the bitcoin
academy for children
yikes is that a real sentence that's a
brand new sentence
no one has ever said that a spokesperson
for the bitcoin academy confirmed to fox
business that the curriculum will
include topics such as what is money
and go on what else is there dave
you have to pick this up george i can't
get my composure so that they cover
topics such as what is money what is
cryptocurrency what is blockchain and
how to keep yourself safe from scammers
oh boy this is the financial literacy
the kids have been needing dave
teaching five-year-olds about blockchain
um
wow the in-person classes will be hosted
two evenings a week and serve
participants dinner a crypto kids camp
program will also take place on two
saturdays for macy marcy kids and teens
ages 5 through 17. the academy will
provide participants with mifi devices
and a one-year limited data plan plus
smartphones if needed oh good good give
the kids internet and smartphones and
load them up with crypto i think that
dinner might be worth more than the
crypto
this is scary it might be worth it just
for the dinner at this point
crypto kids camp those are three words i
never wanted the truth is these two guys
really are trying to do something good
and they have no idea how dumb this is
yes i love them
they're not bad guys they're just trying
to help somebody but
and they're actually you know teaching
something they believe which the problem
with that is it's just wrong
uh not wrong morally but just just
factually and of course the article ends
with the academy's launch comes amid a
volatile time for the cryptocurrency
market
well if anything hope the kids learn a
lesson
wow
this is fascinating well if we've
learned anything from the but we did we
did discover this week that dave ramsey
actually agrees
with the ceo of a crypto company this
headline
that is a headline
ramsay agrees with a c with a crypto ceo
someone pick that up if you're listening
that's a headline right there that's a
twitter headline well it comes from this
dave the chances of me agreeing with
crypto anything's probably really close
to zero
oh yeah but i do completely agree with
this guy on a leadership standpoint
let's be clear well we do we have to
clarify clarific that matters
marketwatch said after petition for
leadership changes coinbase ceo tells
workers to quit if they don't believe in
top execs so there's been this big
petition
in a place where you don't agree with
leadership well you don't trust them you
don't trust leadership that's what he
said which is exactly what i have said
from the stage here in ramsey i tell our
people that all the time don't let the
butt don't let the door hit you in the
butt well and you've also said that no
cults tell you to do that so that which
is a true statement yeah
wow that's uh um
yeah so
yeah
that's
that's a wonderful thing yeah that i
love his reaction to that and by the way
like three days later when crypto dove
they laid off 25 of their employees so
probably the dude that put out the
petition for the ceo's head got fired
which if they'd have discovered him
they'd have fired him too and they
should have because listen if you're so
backward that you think
listen if you if you're a better leader
than your leader is go start something
leave go start something
you don't get to tell him how to run his
deal
that's not that's his deal i'm not going
to tell him how to run his deal i'm
going to tell you not to buy his product
because it's crypto but but i'm going to
tell him how to run his deal
that i just love that
it's um
was a good answer dude glad we found
some middle ground between you and we
found something that i agree on yeah
found something we agree on you got
everybody's got something they agree on
you never know yeah apparently our hair
care products are similar me and you no
him oh okay he's bald guys just for the
record yeah just just just i got excited
i was like dave what are you using these
days this is great this is big news to
me you got excited you used the same
pomade george you just get too excited
too easily all right